Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to John from
Philly? John, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hey, go out. How are you doing?
Speaker 1: Hey, this is John from the D.R.,
right, living in Philly.
Speaker 4: Yes. How are you? You remember.
Speaker 1: I remember you. I remember you.
Speaker 4: How are you? I'm doing well. Very
aware, very aware. So my question is. What
is the deal with the with this Democrat who
is calling the. Without these prior the. Infrastruture
beer. Are they trying to push?
Speaker 1: Are you talking about Chuck Schumer?
I'm not sure who you mean.
Speaker 4: No, the the you know, yeah, the
new Senate, they they tried to push the infrastructure
and they never said anything, I guarantee
to you. Yeah, the Republicans were in control
of the House, the Senate and the White House.
They would push the bill immediately. Oh,
of
Speaker 1: course. Oh, my goodness, John,
if Republicans were in the situation Democrats
are in right now, everything would be done.
They'd have passed tax reform.
Speaker 4: They would just. What is the thing
with the Democrats holding of the bill on
the stand?
Speaker 1: Well, holding up. I mean, part
of the problem, John, is the Democrats aren't
even on the same page about what they want
to pass. You have people like Joe Manchin
and Kirsten Sinema who don't want the same
things that Bernie Sanders wants. And because
they have the slimmest possible majority,
nothing gets done. That's what's going on.
Speaker 4: Yep, I'm going back again to the
same thing. Yeah, like you're OK. Republicans
may block the bill something, but, you know,
they control the White House, you know. Yeah.
You know, maybe Biden can push. We are, you
know. We all support anybody. I'm saying they're
in control. Well, I
Speaker 1: agree and listen, John, if Joe
Biden doesn't get something major done with
Democrats in what's left of this calendar
year, I think Democrats get crushed in next
year's midterm elections.
Speaker 4: I guarantee that that is going
to happen. Yeah, I guarantee they don't. You
know, they're waiting for nothing. Yep.
Speaker 1: There's no. What are they doing?
It makes. I completely agree with you, John.
Speaker 4: It doesn't make no sense waiting
for nothing.
Speaker 1: You're absolutely right. Well,
let's see. Let's see if they get anything
done.
Speaker 4: All right, David Buik, nice talking
to you. You have a wonderful day. You, too.
Speaker 1: There's John from Philly. Great
to hear from him, as always. Why don't we
go next to Vincent from Los Angeles. What's
going on in L.A. these days? Vincent.
Speaker 4: Hmm. Oh, nothing, nothing much.
I haven't been outside in a while.
Speaker 1: Hey, it's good to get some of that
vitamin D, you know.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah, I I wanted to call
in and ask basically, like I was on your show
a lot, and it's an honor to speak to a lot
of things. So I just really like I don't know,
to a lot of what's going on with this sort
of purging of the Republican Party and gets
me and, you know, what's going on with climate
and covid gets me really nervous. So I was
wondering if you could maybe talk about things
that have been going on that might give you,
like, hope as to, you know, things getting
better in the world.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, it's like
if you what might be useful for you and maybe
others as sign up for a good news newsletter.
There are a lot of these which just tell you
about good things that have gone on. You look
at how long are people living on average after
being diagnosed with all types of cancer,
survivability has gone up. You look at, you
know, the you can find positive things that
are going on. Look at the increase, the continued
increased efficiency of solar panels, for
example, or look at the way in which many
countries have shifted more and more towards
alternative energy. You can definitely find
that stuff. But it's also a reality that there's
a lot of really bad things going on right
now. I think it's important to kind of see
both, you know. Yeah, now, I'm curious when
you say you're you're not you're not not going
out because you're depressed about all these
things that are going on and you're just staying
home. Right. Are the two things you mentioned.
They're separate issues.
Speaker 4: That to some extent, to
Speaker 1: some extent, oh, are you like kind
of depressed and just not leaving your house?
Speaker 4: Just dealing with some social anxiety,
I don't know, like one of the greatest things
that's caused me fear is like in particular
like the fear of nuclear weaponry around the
world.
Speaker 1: And that's making you stay home
in some sense.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah, I mean, I don't know
how much I want to talk about it, but yeah,
wow.
Speaker 1: I mean, on a very practical level,
do you think you're safer from nuclear fallout
at home rather than, you know, down the street
at a cafe? Because it seems either way, if
there's nuclear fallout, you just might be
screwed. I don't know. I don't know that I
would worry that much about it in that way.
Speaker 4: That's a very good point.
Speaker 1: I guess I'm just thinking, like,
if there's if there's a nuke that's going
to be dropped, I'd almost rather be at the
basketball court or at the pond rather than
in my house, because either way, it's going
to be bad and I have no control over it. That's
my thought, you know.
Speaker 4: Yeah, it's understandable.
Speaker 1: Yeah, try to get out there, maybe
take a 10 minute walk today, you know.
Speaker 4: Yeah, you know, I think I'll go
ahead and do that. I like now and I'll take
a look at some of the things you mentioned
as to positive signs. Let's do it.
Speaker 1: Let's do it. And I want to hear
from you again. OK, let me know how it goes.
Speaker 4: OK, thank you very much. Great
talking,
Speaker 1: we got to get out there. With that
said, that makes me sad. We really, you know,
staying at home in order to avoid the bomb.
I mean, I'd rather be having a cappuccino.
You know, I think that's the that's the situation
for me.